today to our country to all the fallen warriors
around the world for the fact that you and I are Russian and
this is our country which we love very much.
Let us together
[applause]
[music]
strive steadily for our lot to
live, and the time has come to realize that all of
you are not new, that  the mouth is filled with human enmity
again Oh, this knowledge is
late or early, which is
broadcast on the screens, that the pain cannot be canceled
or delayed, it will bleed in us for a long time,
every century from time immemorial
begins for our country with a war with the
collective West and every time the people are the
feat of a common man.  the name of love for the
fatherland predetermined the victory of Russian
weapons
17th century
Polish-Lithuanian intervention and the
Nizhny Novgorod People's Militia
expelling the enemy from the capital 18th century
Northern War victory of Peter I in Poltava and the
Russian Empire appeared on the world map
with a powerful regular army and
navy 19th century Napoleon's invasion First
Patriotic War  when the Partisan
people's movement played a decisive role
in the destruction of the multinational
Napoleonic Horde, which outnumbered the
Russian army three times, Napoleon's great army of the
French was no more than
half the rest. The
twentieth century, two world wars, the
bloodiest in the history of mankind,
history does not change itself, and today at the
beginning of the 21st century we are again
we resist the West, protecting the Russian
people and again persistently We remind the world
not to fight with the Russians
[music]
Luzhnikov Today we have gathered here For the
Glory of the defenders of the Fatherland,
tomorrow is a special day for this year we
again realized that in Russia there are only two
real allies - the army and the navy, but strength
and not invincibility  the army
is always based on the faith and love of the people
of its defenders. Today we will
tell you and show you the heroes of a special
military operation,
senior lieutenant Sergei Lomov,
members of the Militia since 2014, when the
special operation began, his commander
was called there, he did not hesitate to
follow him as a volunteer Sergei Ross in
Ukraine, but chose  side of the people of
Donbass and found a father from whom he was
separated in early childhood,
we invite Sergey
[music]
let's applaud our
heroes
[applause]
this year was very difficult for us,
each of us was disappointed Some in
relatives Some in close friends Who
comrades Ukraine wanted to destroy us
and we had to take up arms to
protect our families, children, women,
old people and our Earth
in the hospital after a serious wound, I
found a father whom I had not seen in a strange
childhood,
many of us who are at the front
have lost very close ones, not only in spirit,
but also in heart.
Sorry, I’m worried
about  in any case, we are all worried about this
year, I wanted to say that each of us
found a family, not only by blood, not
just by blood, we
found a family with the name Russia Thank you
very much thank you very much in the
fall of 22 The Fatherland Called faithful sons into service
Artyom Ponomarev One of those
mobilized in  the day of his farewell to the army, his
grandfather gave him an aluminum mug with the
inscription fighter not a step back, and
Artyom fulfilled this order from his grandfather at the end of January,
carrying out his task. The brigade was
attacked by the Ukrainian Nazis.
Artyom got the wounded, dragged them
around, saving them from direct shelling,
trying to drag his friend, was
fired upon and received  severe head wound,
soldier of the 254th
motorized rifle regiment of the assault detachment of the
assault battalion, Artyom Ponomarev,
was presented with a
state award for his feat.
Let's give him the floor to welcome
[applause]
first of all, I want to express words of
gratitude and support to our guys
who are right now, through that blood,
bringing ours closer  victory in the zone of a
special military operation, brothers, we are
together and Step by step, bridges and the truth and
strength of the Russian people Yes, I
couldn’t even think of myself, I’ll become a military man, lived in an ordinary
life, studied and worked hard, the
front is not only the Front line, and
transferring this is not only the control of a
gun  the front is all of us. Each of us is
here now,
and the sooner each of us understands this and
begins to do everything in
our power for the front line, the sooner we will cleanse our
Earths of these non-humans.
I want to say a special thank you to the doctors
and nurses who are with us at the front and at
risk.  with his life he saves ours. Low
bow to you
Artyom Sergey thank you very much we are
proud of you thank you thank you
Grigory Leps knows like no one else that
for the recovery of the wounded we need not
only doctors but also artists who do not abandon their own
[music]
[applause]
but also pull on the nerves
Let the brave heart
rise, the first
fear is no more no more
And we all know this,
strong people
do not abandon their
[music]
[applause] if you don’t
defeat her, I
will stand for you Russia mother, the
concept of honor
[music]
does not abandon
hopes with love
[music]
[applause]
today as before
[music]
for your mother
[music] I will
stand for you to the Russians
[applause]
is calling
[music] I
will stand for you Russia mother
[music]
Don’t let her down
and for you
Russia mother
[music]
we started a special operation to protect the
Russian people
but we faced a cynical enemy
hiding behind the civilian population as a shield,
their usual practice is to
methodically fire NATO
shells at peaceful cities, also their
usual practice, they are not stopped by the fact
that they destroy hospitals, schools, residential
buildings. Bus stops. On December 6,
one of the nine victims of Ukrainian cities
right in the heart of Donetsk turned out to be Maria
Pirogova, a volunteer who many  for years
she was at the epicenter of people's troubles, she took
out warmed her, comforted and delighted her
fellow countrymen with her creativity.
Can you just a little
[music]
call your family so
Where are we going,
of course, the voice also vote
[music]
Bergsky and we must fight for them
Russia city
[music]
[applause]
that day Maria was going to the studio to
record this new song that
you and I just heard.
And the words for this song were written by
my mother Pirogova and she is with us today
[applause]
Thank you for your daughter, thank you for
raising a true patriot of ours
countries Thank you
dear friends
to do good It's great That's what
my daughter Maria Pirogova always said,
each of you can help people, for
this you just need to look around
If you
start helping at least someone
especially If you start helping children
who have no one else to help it will change
you inside first of all
it is
vitally important to continue Masha’s work
[music]
Look around, next to each of you there
may be someone
who needs our
help Thank you, thank you very much,
low bow for raising such an
amazing daughter Thank you very much
Victoria Daineko Natalya Kachura and the ballet
Todes with the song my city
[music]
Wake me up mom early to the
hail rain
[music]
[music] [
music]
My city smelled like gunpowder on my neck My city
we knitted
[music]
under the hail sky,
broken, unconquered, my
city stands, missing
gunpowder, my city
[music]
unconquered  stands
bells
again coldly
signed up for Death along
your roadmen when in your head
Wake me up mom Hello
Let the dawn be I will find everything
[applause]
outside the window of
the answer
we separate ours and strangers
[music]
My city is lost
My city
[music]
not conquered is
yours  city ​​novel
shiboram My city
[music]
[applause] [
music] [music] [
applause] [music] [
applause]
stands
[music]
[applause]
You remember me alive These lines from Pyotr
Kazakov call on all of us to believe in
Victory for our soldiers
[music]
[applause]
Let's support
you
[applause]
[music]
I was assigned to the immortal regiment as a shrapnel soldier
and until the farewell musicians
played
You remember me alive and not as a line on a
memorial because I
believed, loved, served, and such as  I
was not by blood to the guys in life and will forever
remain a brother
Don’t be sad
Remember me without dressing up in rough boots as a
nice guy with an open heart
only the one who fought the
show himself forward sparing no effort knows the value of
holy words Mom
Motherland home Russia
fulfilling the filial duty of
a teenager You are the last of the battle  I am entering the
Immortal Floor
so that the Earth
does not leave Orbit The
combat path of volunteer Alyasa Avetsba
began in 2008 when Georgia began
military operations against Abkhazia First,
we Swan joined the
International Brigade Fifteen
Grateful Donetsk People's Republic
awarded him the St. George Cross,
third degree, a
true Highlander must defend the truth  and
justice, which means Russia and its
people
Good afternoon Moscow
good afternoon Russia
[music]
dear friends First of all, I want to
congratulate you on the holiday and say
hello to fulfill my promise to all
the guys who
are currently at the front of the guys Hello to you
[applause]
I have arrived  I was brought there to Donetsk with the beginning of a special
military operation by a
sense of duty and
gratitude to the people of Russia, the
people of Donbass,
I saw with my own eyes the result of the
activities of neo-Nazis, these are
tortured children,
women, old people,
burned destroyed cities,
this encouraged us all to take up
arms and stand up for defense, for this is ours
in the blood to protect in the blood of all Russians
Abkhazia in the Ossetians Chechens Tatars Buryats
to help us all The
International Brigade Fifteen
in its ranks united representatives of the
entire former Soviet Union
we are united by one sacred goal
to protect our common home the
ancient Abkhazian wisdom says And
now the kazatil write with evil The
land not sprinkled  it cannot
be blood. The Motherland is just a damp Earth. The Earth is the
land for which we are
fighting today; it is not just speckled with blood;
it is thoroughly saturated with the blood of our
ancestors, and now with our blood. And
this means This is our common Motherland and We
must win and let No one
doubt  we will definitely win, happy
holiday friends Thank you
very much
Miner Konstantin Kuzmin commander of the
third territorial
defense battalion named after the 383rd Mining Division in
2014 Kuzmin
put forward an Ultimatum to Kiev if the
punitive operation is not stopped within 48 hours
and Ukrainian troops are not withdrawn
miners will replace the jackhammer
with a machine gun
Kuzmin kept his word, the
miners created a battalion and named it
the same way as the division of
Miners natives of Donbass was once called during the Great
Patriotic War since 2014, behind the
shoulders of Kuzmin’s unit, the protection of
Devaytsev and Lavaisk is small, today
they are working in the Ugledar direction,
word to battalion commander Konstantin
Aleksandrovich Kuzmin, holder of the
St. George  Cross fourth third
second degree
Good afternoon dear friends Good afternoon
dear brothers and sisters
Exactly 9 years ago the Kiev junta, by its
deprivation, deprived us of the
inhabitants of Donbass, on our Donbass
land, blood was shed, the blood of
civilians, the blood of children they killed every
day
They talked about what it was  Russian
Propaganda that no one kills anyone,
that it’s all a lie, but behind their lies,
more than 15 thousand civilians died in 9 years,
that’s why in 14 we
couldn’t do otherwise. All of us, All those who
stood up for the defense of our families of our Motherland,
we stood for the future  our children and
the future is natural where the Donetsk
Donbass
all of us the Donetsk People's Republic of
Lugansk this is only in Russia this is the path
that will be ensured for our children will give
the future so now we stand shoulder to
shoulder at the very forefront We are
fulfilling our duty we are defending our
land our our
land our  we can’t
do otherwise, our motherland is behind us
I know one thing is that victory will be with us Happy
holidays to you Konstantin
Thank you very much by the way for Konstantin
to defend his land His daughter has followed him
and is standing guard,
we all owe this Thank you in the
special military zone  operations
are being carried out by the United group of the
Armed Forces of Russia and the National Guard under
the command of Colonel Alexander
Beloglazov, the fighters of the Vityaz detachment only
in the first two months of the special operation managed to capture eighteen enemy strongholds,
suppressed over 50 firing
points,
destroyed 30 armored vehicles,
Colonel Beloglazov not only personally
commanded these operations,
destroying 15 militants but  and under
mortar fire from the enemy, he brought the fighters out of the
fire
Meet the heroes of Russia Head of the
special forces center Vityaz Colonel
Alexander Beloglazov
[applause]
Good day friends
Today we are defending our people and our
peaceful life, we did
not declare this war, but we accepted the
challenge
We accepted the challenge and are ready
prove once again that you stand and will withstand all
the difficulties of the test
no matter what and in spite of everything we
will win
and today our main task is
to become stronger
because being strong is a guarantee of the
national security of our
state Thank you very much
Alexander Happy Holidays Thank you
and we are waiting for one throughout the country  our common
victory and we believe that it will definitely be
ours Yes, I can’t hear you
because our cause is just, the enemy will be
defeated Victory will definitely be ours
now it’s a difficult time now the so-
called Western civilized world
has taken up arms against us But we are of the same blood and we want to
win, our guys want  good luck in battle
Because Ruslan said so We are all of the
same blood
[music]
[music] [
music]
Star dust
[music]
on boots
soft chair
sunny day
near five dreams
Blood type on the sleeve My serial
number
Wish me good luck in battle
already
no
holes
[music]
Wish me luck
I have something to pay but I don’t want
Victory at any cost
I
don’t want to put my foot on anyone’s chest
I wanted to stay with you
[music]
that Wish me good luck in battle
wish
[music]
[applause]
Blood type on the sleeve My serial
number on the sleeve
Wish me luck in battle
Wish me luck
in this grass
Don’t stay I
wish you luck
[music]
[applause] [
music]
[applause]
[music]
Wish me luck
Olga Kormukhina Alexander look  Dmitry
Kharatyan Dmitry Dyuzhev
Akimovachev Kirill Kuznetsov Ruslan
Astashko Korsakova group the day after tomorrow
[applause]
March 15,
2022,
during a reconnaissance raid behind
enemy lines,
24-year-old Van Lukin was killed
and the actor
his unit was surrounded for 24
hours under constant machine-gun
fire. Ivan held back a superior
strength of the enemy, he protected
civilians who were hiding in the basement the
next day, covering the withdrawal of his
unit, Ivan was killed by a sniper, here is the
last message to his father from the machine gunner of the
reconnaissance company of the Guard sailor 810
separate Guards Marine Brigade of the
Black Sea Fleet
Ivan Lukin,
we are leaving
as usual today suddenly, so what to do
with it later  I understand with a smile
Hello everyone
My name
today is with us the father of the deceased
hero, holder of the Order of Courage Ivan
Lukin, Boris Ivanovich, the
floor to you
[applause]
my son left the walls of the literary
institute and left to defend the fatherland like
his great-grandfather and grandfather during the Great
Patriotic War 45 they defeated the fascism of the
departments  my father and my grandfather were in the building
now when I am sorting out my son’s archive and
preparing the publication of his work.
I especially acutely understand how
deeply he understood the meaning of his life,
that’s why such lines were born from him,
this path was bequeathed to me by God, this path
creates me
to be worthy of our fallen, this is one  of
our tasks with you and besides this Our
task is to do everything For victory only for the sake of
victory every beat of our heart for
victory every beat of every breath we
must win we cannot help but win
and we will be winners this is how I live Father of
a soldier
Thank you very much Thank you
For the glory of no  crushed Russian soldier
legendary group Lyube
[applause]
[music]
third day on the road
wind stones rains
all forward and spiers
mouth will die our ancestors
third day on the road Hey
brother Don’t be sad
because an order is an order
Each of us knows
Write a letter
he is not
more valuable than I am
the fighters  Write a few words
Go out to the chat for your boys
[music]
light a cigarette Come on, senior sergeant I believe in
your soul, soldier, soldier,
you go forward at dawn, a company of soldiers
leaves to win and so as not to take your foot off the pedal,
light a cigarette there, comrade senior
sergeant, I believe in your soul,
soldier
[  music]
wind to me rains
at dawn for us
[music]
third day on the road
Who would know what awaits ours
[music]
third day on the road
and the dawn comes
[music]
Write a letter about
how our parent lives there
[music]
from far away  - far away
they will bring it to me
[music]
mouth leaves
[music] light a
cigarette comrade senior sergeant I believe
in your soul soldier soldier soldier and at
dawn
ahead of labor the soldier leaves to
win and not to clean up
there light a cigarette comrade senior sergeant I
believe in the soul  yours
[music]
Earth fell from the sky earth
in the sky choke
and at dawn the kind of soldier
leaves to win and so as not to die we
fly there to light a cigarette comrade senior
sergeant I believe in your soul
soldier soldier soldier and at dawn a
company of soldiers leaves forward to
win  and in order not to die You let
Comrade Senior Sergeant have a light I believe
in your soul
soldier
[music]
You specifically for a military operation have your own
unofficial anthem
333 it was written by a retired colonel, a
combat veteran and now
a volunteer from Tambov Alexander Vanyushkin
Alexander Vanyushkin is Vasily Terkin
of our days
[music]
I just took an accordion
and went to the front to raise the spirit of our
soldiers, because defending your homeland
is not only a choice, it is the sacred duty of
every person,
if the army is supported by the entire people, this
army is invincible.
Thanks to
our soldiers who do their
heroic work.
Thanks to those who forge ours.  victory In the rear
[applause]
songs we will win,
but for those who are against us we have one
answer
three hundred
thirty-three
you, as they say on the berlovaya,
we work brothers
[applause]
[music]
by car
clearly corrects
[music]
[  music]
in the car, swastika behind the wheel
[music]
on wheels, a coffin And after that
before sunset 330
[music]
put the younger ones
From dawn to dusk
means call mother for Russia
333 17
[music]
u  Azamat Turlanova Two grandfathers were
tankers, he is also a tanker. And since
October, the Captain of the new T-90 Breakthrough tank,
and she also found herself in difficult
combat situations more than once. But every time the T-90 Breakthrough tank
showed itself to be a reliable machine,
for example, when a shell fell on the tank’s turret.  The
enemy's copter, the car caught fire,
so the T-90 breakthrough was able to drive
173 km on its own and the crew remained safe and sound, and
today the tank commander Azamaturlanov is with us
[applause]
[music]
T9 the breakthrough of my unit appeared a long time ago. Well,
I got into the crew of the combat vehicle already
as
This wonderful vehicle has great
advantages,
it has a panoramic sight for the commander
who can observe the entire
battle situation, we want to share our
experience and say how much better the
survivability of the combat vehicle and its
crew, for example, was blown up by a mine, but
we did not stop and continued to
return to duty and  we were dropped again from a
copter, a cumulative projectile
caught fire, but we didn’t stop
and returned under our own power to the repair base
after traveling 173 kilometers.
I want to say that defense is not only
people, not only soldiers, but also
defense is armor and iron.
I want to say a big thank you to the defense
industry for helping to preserve
us Our lives
and bring closer the day of our Great Victory
Hurray Thank you, I
know,
I of course warmed the eyes of each of them
at the memory of the home of the beloved
who, although far away, still loves
and waits for each era for its songs about the
beloved of our grandfathers and great-grandfathers The Great
Patriotic War warmed  Katyusha and the
current front-line soldier, commander of a
reconnaissance platoon,
reconnaissance company, senior lieutenant
Nikolai Romanenko wrote his own, because he is
sure that descendants will call this war
Great
[music]
flowers on your windowsill And I am your admirer from the bouquets of
lovers, you do not give
me peace even in my dreams, my Katyusha My
spring  I saw a trial in which only the
two of us are liquid Sun summer pond and we
sing about how good it is for us for another moment
this hand in hand with the baby, but I recognize him,
my whole face of happiness God, she began to
smile
sounds, I wake up and the old mother
is crying at home at the window, son  Wake up, the
war has come to our home
[music]
Lord is open
[music] the
face is
heavy The hour has come And we didn’t wait for it I was
looking forward to the beginning of a happy life but
nothing was ringing and there was no city
on the butt There were faces Yes, I’m kidding dear
that they didn’t give me This  all the dust, it all doesn’t
make sense, but I want my friend to
say his words - this is my grandfather, he
fought bravely for his Motherland and I don’t know Katya,
what will happen next, I know that we will win,
we are appointed and I am not afraid to put my hands
in blood, this is war  and we didn’t
start it We finished it When the
bright red flag is sure to rise in Berlin,
but for now the scarlet blood is very good, this
war is very good and the descendants will call it great
[music]
don’t cry for them Don’t cry for me Katyusha
misses your eyes so close Fate seems to
have united  souls and so cruelly
separated us We are alive alive my Katyusha
for evil to enemies a traitor for envy so
that they don’t say anything don’t listen they say I’m
dead it seemed to them no matter what happens the
main thing is to remember that I
don’t need anything except your love
at the front I’m a proud warrior who really
wants to become  a kind husband and I will return from
the threshold, I will hug you quietly, I will cry quietly, as
if childishly, on the lower finger, your
ring pulled on forever, the soldier
sits down
[music] [
music]
[music]
Every time we go to our soldiers
in the zone of a special military
operation, we always take  with us
letters that are written by all citizens of our
country, from young to old,
we here do not understand what
this piece of paper written with a pen means in a trench, but
we know exactly how important these
lines are to a soldier, how they literally
protect them and bring our common victory closer
[music  ]
[music]
Don’t be afraid
Hello soldier We don’t know each other at all,
you’re in the trenches now, but I, of course,
I’m writing to God to just say
thank you
for a quiet life and for peace
[music]
I’m lucky, I haven’t heard
so many shells exploding
and calm strength
la
how would
you return with Victory I know
tomorrow will bring me simple
worries
school friends mom and dad return from
work
[music]
and you have again transmitting
you will return soldier you will return with
victory I know
you are lucky to have you next to me
I didn’t hear how your projectile is spinning
and the calm power is
let go then you will return through Victory
I know
[music]
I know there are
many children among us, these are not ordinary
children
and not from Mariupol,
during the liberation of Mariupol these
guys
were saved by an angel
angel  this is the call sign of a serviceman from
Chelyabinsk, the father of seven children, Yuri
Gagarin, in early March he went to the
front line. Although he could have stayed at home, this
year told a lot about us, many
left their usual way of life and
went to volunteer in the
special operation zone.
Yuri Leonidovich Gagarin saved
367 children in Mariupol  That's how it was
now, I'm going to
quickly cross this road,
don't cry, let's go, don't be afraid, take it, uncle
[music] The
children you saved And remember Anya
Naumenko She's here now wants to say
important words
Anechka, smart girl, don't hesitate to speak We're with
you, we're close Thank you, Uncle Yuri  the fact
that he saved me, my sister and hundreds of thousands of
children in Mariupol,
I just a little bit
[applause]
Anyuta Don’t be shy, you can come up and
hug, look, children Let’s all hug
Look, he’s the one who saved you, it’s
not in vain that the call sign angel is true Irina, you have my
word,
these are children, children of Donbass  children of Mariupol
These are our children and we the Russian army
are obliged to
protect this people and these children we are a
strong army we are a mighty army but
your support is important to us
[applause]
we are together we
will win
[applause]
the truth is behind us God and our families
will protect our Earth from  gray plague Thank you
Thank you
[applause]
Thank you Thank you very much
write me
a letter later as if I were alive,
but write about happiness, not about grief
Write to me about what you see out the window of the
endless blue sea What's on the sea On the
blue, a boat floats with a
silvery catch richly  that the
space fleet was spread out over him,
snow-white Russian cotton wool
I broke this time with my hands like steel,
kissed him on his black lips Write about
love, don’t write about sadness Write that I
took Mariupol, write I won’t give you to anyone,
my dear, we’ll see you soon
I didn’t die I  I’m sleeping and the Sea of ​​Azov is approaching my boots
Mariupol, the Russian city of milk
[music] [
music]
[music]
I open the video with the view that the joint was in
the description of
VK
[music]
In milk we are
glad to go home
[music] a
stranger beyond the Carpathians with a thief  then the calibers
begin the primarams of the likar we steal for
God you came for the Ukrainian doctor of steel
Chervona Kalina right keys in the
place of Mary of Jesus meet St.
George too I will be a
foul-mouthed killer Tell the
lie About the nose beard to him that the word is
[ __ ] I’m the same [ __ ] kingdom
[music]
cold weather
[applause]
[music]
shame old
milk
[music] [
music]
Today, February 22 is the day before the
Defender of the Fatherland Day holiday in
different years - this day was the day of the Red
Army, the day of the Soviet Army, the
Navy, the military day
glory of Russia
but under any name for more than a hundred years on
February 23, the
Russian people honor our defenders of the
defenders of the Motherland who with their lives
defend the freedom and independence of
our state of Russia
For the glory of the defenders of the Fatherland
Oleg Gazmanov
[applause]
people will drink
[music]
Gentlemen, officer
she  drawn out
I when the world
sings this song to
those who ask for a career
[music] the
latitude, without sparing
its chest, offers its breasts
for Russia
to those who survived in Afghanistan
without harming their honor,
who did not make a career from
soldier’s blood
I sing as an officer to the
mothers who took pity
[music]
returning them back  sons alive
Officers
[music]
Gentlemen officers
how to save your Faith
to pieces
your souls are wheezing
what have we done brothers we
could not save them
And now they are always
leaving guys
[music]
Russia has called them
as it has happened more than once
and again you are leaving
Maybe  straight to the sky
And from somewhere above
[music]
Farewell to us
So where are you going
[music]
and from somewhere light from above
Farewell to us
[music]
heart at gunpoint
for Russia and freedom to the end
Russian officers
forcing their
hearts to sound in unison
[music]  ]
[applause]
[music]
officers,
your heart is at gunpoint for Russia and
freedom to the end [
music]
making your hearts sound in unison
[music]
Thank you
[applause]
So, people are not frozen
Let's move more cheerfully [
applause]
[music]
[music]  ]
also the sky and are carved
Soldiers of
Russia
Victory soldiers
[music]
When the battle comes
we will fight and fulfill the grandfathers and fathers that
our land stood
forward
Soldiers of Russia
[music] [
applause] [applause] [music
]
[applause]
[music]
Now  the whole world is in your hands with you,
friends in the fleet within the framework Years will pass and
you will understand that it was not in vain that you endured the heat
Soldiers of Russia
[applause]
[applause] the
liberation of Mariupol this is an epic
page of our special operation, the matter
was complicated by the fact that the Nazis made
firing points right in high-rise buildings
civilians Old men
women children on the path of our troops
our army literally advanced with its
hands tied, trying to save the lives of
every civilian often at the cost of
their own February
2022 the men of Donbass left their
homes and went to defend their homeland
artists of the Lugansk Philharmonic
exchanged their musical instruments for
machine guns
divisions of philharmonicists among  was the
first to enter Mariupol and held the
nine-story building, this was a key position
because further on there was access to the sea
thanks to the capture of this particular
nine-story building, the Azov national gap
was surrounded and the fascists began to
squeeze out the word from the private sector to the
artist of the Lugansk Philharmonic
Anatoly Lavrentyev, who was awarded a
medal for the liberation of Mariupol and an
order for  military valor of the second
degree
Anatoly Your word
should never be repeated on
our Russian lands
when our women, children, old people suffer. It
doesn’t matter who you are as a musician or a miner, you are a
man and you must come to their defense,
we musicians from the very beginning of the special operation
put aside their musical instruments,
notes and among  the first to go to defend
our Earth and our loved ones We had no
combat experience,
we will have one victory, one for all,
today the artists of the Lugansk Philharmonic
will return to their peaceful profession for one evening
together with Polina Gureeva and the
choir of the twice-Red Banner Order of the
Red Star
academic song and dance ensemble
Russian army named after Alexandrov
[music]
and only we, shoulder to shoulder,
are growing into the ground, here the
planet is burning and spinning, there is
smoke above our homeland, and that means we need
one victory, one for all. We can’t stand the price,
one for all. We can’t stand the price,
waiting for us.  mortal fire
and all
doubt is powerless
Our tenth airborne battalion Our
tenth airborne battalion
As soon as there is a landmine battle, another
order sounds and the postman will go crazy
looking for us,
don’t let The red rocket
hits the machine gun, it won’t tire you and So we
need one victory, one for all We
won’t stand behind our backs
one for all We will not stand behind the wall Healthy
lifestyle without Silva
doubt goes away into the night
separate
Our tenth airborne battalion
[music]
let go the
war has come on the most hostile breeds
such as things
but not Putin let’s remember this
[music]
today We need one  victory
is one for all, we are socialistenon will not stand
from all of us Vysotsky's death
Jesus is
powerless for me I ask it will be hotels again
Our tenth airborne battalion
[music]
and stingrays once an airborne battalion
and now it’s not even a call song, a symbol of
our special military operation
[music]
[applause]
we will stand
with you for now We lived and the truth is behind us
There is someone looking at us from above with their own
eyes,
they smiled like children and outside we will stand
and the show will become closer to them The
Lord and the truth are with us
we will say Thank you for what  we were given victory
for those who found their heaven and we will no longer stand with
us
and the song will begin
[music]
will remain in our hearts
at the end
x we ​​will
stand
and Let's remember all those who were lost in this window
who walked and died for freedom and were not swept away
I  I know that we will definitely
meet with you
[music] we
will be
drawn in again
[music]
Hero of Russia
to the end
[music]
our time
between us
Heroes of Russia will remain in our
[music]
end my friends, the
whole country is watching us now Come on, let’s be noisy
loud
Let's welcome everyone and say once again a
huge thank you to all our defenders of the
Fatherland
[applause]
our guys on the front line now really
need our support our warm
words our help that we are collecting from the whole
country says that the people and the
army are united these are not empty words this is
what  Now our guys there on the front line
feel like never before, they know that
the heart of every citizen of our country
beats for them. Meet the participants in the
special military operation,
among them are pilots, infantrymen, artillerymen, paratroopers, tank crews
and Moriks
[applause]
in the territory controlled by
the President of the Russian Federation Vladimir
Vladimirovich Putin
[applause]
dear  friends
Good afternoon
[applause]
we are meeting with you on the eve of
Defender of the Fatherland Day in this
phrase there is something huge and powerful in these words
I would say
mystical and sacred for good reason one of the
most famous prayers begins with the
words Our Father
[music]
People Who A  Making
and Fighting
[music] yes
looking for hir avokol
Yes sapotit byta hou kanji Enderman
hu from tuning from ols defenderlandica
Yes because of the flavor of
empluisol defensector chance portation
Sector everyone the world
All of you Here whive Come hear To
seports a ua solius Thank you
genehuaw  riting
S BMW
[applause]
When you are together we have no equal for the
unity of the Russian people Hurray
[applause]
Russia
we all know what is happening now will
certainly end in victory because
our strength in
truth
victory will be ours Glory to our
defenders of the fatherland Thank you and  a
low bow
[music]
in the reflection of the water follows
something now in parting Tell me
something tell me something
Hold on
I'll be with you
[applause]
[music]
and I'll be with you
[music]  ]
undoubtedly
Piranessi was right
[music]
shu you
[applause]
[music]
Slava Wait,
I'll be with you
[applause]
[music] [
applause] [
music] [
music]
[applause]
[music]
[music] [
music]
[applause]
I will be
with you [applause] liberation of Mariupol there are many
heroes and feats and here is one of them,
holder of the Order of Courage Anton Simonov,
commander of the Marine Corps with the call sign rokot
Mariupol, he was blown up on a mini and lost his
leg but already  recovered and returned
back to the front line and
walked 16 km on his own
hello He knows today friends
You have a word
in life, everyone has different
situations But it doesn’t end there You
need to take everything into your own strength to move forward I
want to say words of support to all those
who are now in difficult times  situations
After all, the main thing for yourself is to set goals
and go towards them
no matter what
Anton, we are proud of you We are glad that we have
such real defenders of the fatherland Yes
friends
Thank you all
Thank you war is hard Men's work
but in heaven women are nowhere especially
like junior sergeant  Kristina
Kristina Kim is a nurse from Tula, she is only
27, they dedicate poems to her, sing songs, draw
pictures on her shoulders, this girl, under
heavy enemy fire, carried
12 adult men from the battlefield.
Many of the paratroopers, of course, were surprised how 12 people were possible
because you are wearing armor, you are wearing a
helmet.  musing and on it the same thing,
you can only run
to it, crawl to it, and when it’s all
being shot, when it’s all exploding
next to you, you don’t even pay attention to this.
help Well, as an assistant to a surgeon, she
performs the most complex operations. We
provide assistance to all the military there, but also to
children and grandmothers. For
seven years she has been working in the Military
Hospital of the 106th Airborne Division, like other
paratroopers, she is an excellent shooter with a
machine gun and has been jumping with a parachute since she was 20 years old and
came here right away.  I was put on the
post since then, sisters, first special operations,
on the account of junior sergeant Kim, hundreds of
saved lives, not only military but also
civilians, when you are there,
this is not even a decision, this is not a choice, it’s
just an immediate action. I don’t
regret one bit that I chose this
profession Nobody  besides us, the words of the
Airborne Forces commander Ivan Starchek,
spoken near Moscow during the Great
Patriotic War, became the motto of all
Paratroopers. Nobody but us, this is also
about all the military Medics who, like
Christina Kim, serve the Motherland In the name of life,
because in war, doctors are second only to
God,
junior sergeant is with us  nurse of the 39th
separate medical detachment of the
airborne troops Kristina Kim, the
decree on awarding Kristina has already been signed
and in the near future she will be presented with a
state award Kristina Over to you
Hello friends
[applause]
Our task
is to save people's lives
and the goal is a
peaceful sky above your head
Where there is pain, suffering, I  I realized for myself
that there is no place for weakness, the
courage of our fighters, their strength of spirit
forces us to act and go Only
forward and we must unite as one
to save the country
and protect Our lives from danger,
men,
women, children,
the fight is for the lives of each of us, no
one is here  will come and will not do this
work for us,
on my own behalf
and on behalf of all our soldiers,
from the bottom of my heart I want to thank
everyone who believes in us and supports us, we
will win
Thank you very much [
music]
people who live in our country
during the Great Patriotic War
armor  fascist tigers and Panthers were burned by
our
Soviet self-propelled gun ISU-152
and the Soldiers simply called it St. John's wort
group St. John's wort Our victory
[music]
wait,
why do you need to go there,
but when
these pathetic types repeat that it’s someone else’s misfortune
that you consider not yours, it doesn’t matter to me
I
My people my temples are
sacred our Earth
but it blooms
[music]
threatens to abandon
[music] we will
end this war in our victory
[music]
we will laugh with eternal fire the vain
one who opened Pandora's Box will regret
it
we will come forever win and end the
war
where  our princes built
[music]
where under the red stars the grandfathers saved the
new world
suddenly the military laboratories of rubbish
paid off
ordered us to throw the plague of the world
river
dirty hands dirty bomb
owls
[music]
how many terrible finds Azov buried in the
catacombs
So it’s destined to sum up the inglorious
conclusion
[music]  ]
we will end this war with our Victory
[music]
we will come forever to win and end the
war
[music]
we will end this war with our Victories
[music] of
our Victory
we will come forever win and end the
war
[music]
[applause]
Thanks to all our guys there on the
front line, know that we believe in you, we are
proud of you,
Glory to the defender of the Fatherland
[music]